you have said that you wish German was
your first language well I had a dream
about a year ten years ago it was very
very odd because I've always liked the
Germans and I like Germany and I had
this dream there were three guys sort of
50 60 year-old sir dark suits and the
only thing I remember about the dream is
the last thing I said before I woke up
was my only regret is that German was
not my first language no and you don't
speak any German I have a very good
accent an excellent accent and I know a
little bit of jerk you can you can you
know a little bit of German yeah well we
we did a Monty Python in German did you
know that we went to Munich and we that
we wrote it in English and they
translated it and so and you did it all
in the German all did it in German in
totally in German and I learned very
useful phrases like he can medina mile
er Phyllida monitor which means I can
kill bats with an eggs become in very
heavy use that before I did one so this
is absolute I went to some police
function because they wanted me to draw
the raffle and at the end a nice young
British copper came up to me and said
this is Heidi my German girlfriend she
doesn't speak any English at all can you
say something through someone said I can
with a teaspoon kill bats and she looked
at me and said Vicki wasn't that a great
clip subscribe to my youtube channel for
an endless supply of me
[Laughter]